Warhawk
so you want to be a Gwent master you're
probably thinking oh I've beaten every
single merchant in The Witcher 3 I don't
need to listen to this guy well things
are kind of different this time around
the basics are still intact but the
finer details have been changed so here
are my five tips on how to kick ass in
the Gwent beta this should be a
no-brainer for anyone who's played Gwent
in the witcher 3 or any card game for
that matter you won't be drawing a new
card each turn so don't play all your
big guns right out of the gate unlike
Gwent in the witcher 3 you do draw two
cards at the beginning of the second
round and one at the beginning of the
third round this can act as a cushion
but don't rely on it chances are you
probably won't get the exact cards you
need by the rate of more halt planning
ahead also means that sometimes you
might have to throw around if you in the
first round don't overwork yourself to
win the second the last thing you want
is to be low on resources during that
final critical round I say you should
stay on pace with your opponent so he or
she burns through resources but don't go
all-in unless you are certain you can
win
in the tutorial it says to play your
hero cards early on but I say no any
last words
bluffing plays a huge role in Gwent and
if you play Geralt at the beginning your
opponent is going to know that one
you have Geralt in your deck and two
you've already used him instead I like
to play weaker cards and cards that
don't have any special abilities at the
beginning just to see how my opponent
plays I save Geralt for the very end if
it's coming down to the wire on that
third round and you play Geralt that's
basically a wind condition if an
opponent plays a hero card right at the
beginning in the first round I usually
start playing defensively and in most
cases I give that round to my opponent
because now I know Geralt is no longer a
problem
once again if you've played card games
then you know that it's better to keep
your deck on the leaner side there's no
point in filling your deck with cards
that could come in handy in very
specific situations instead look for
cards that serve multiple purposes and
build on your overall strategy a six
strength card like this one that gets +1
each turn in the fog isn't the best card
to have if you aren't focusing on
weather effects strategies sure a six
strength is decent but you'd be better
to find a card that fits your play style
this dip is kind of dependent on which
deck you choose the main but when I
place Galaga or northern realms I try to
pick cards for two rows and avoid cards
from the third then I pick whether cards
accordingly for example when I play
Northern realms I load my deck with
siege and infantry units and thrown a
couple fog cards
this way I can significantly weaken one
of my opponents lanes and because I
don't have many mid-range cards I should
come out unscathed
I tend to use my leader as a guide when
I'm building a deck unfortunately you
only start with one leader for each
faction at the beginning of the beta but
there are still plenty of good
strategies to build off of them
if Skellig ax is more your style than
I'd focus on cars that increase in
strength when cards on your side of the
battlefields have been weakened the
leader ability is to place to plan on
crate warriors when you place this card
it automatically loses to strength this
sounds like an awful ability at first
but if you play this with some other
cards it can be deadly for example the
clam tourists each x-men games to
strength for each unit on your side of
the battlefield that has its strengths
reduced but isn't destroyed you can take
things further with a clan broke VAR
Archer he deals one damage to three
units if you hit your own cards with
that then our clan Axman gets an extra
six strength but we aren't done yet or
cry doubles the strength of all your
units that have had their strength
reduced
now you're looking at a pretty deadly
board state and that's just one of the
many examples we saw obviously this is
still a beta so things could change but
in the meantime I hope this helps and if
you have any other tips please leave
them in the comments below or if you
want to take me on at Gwen find me on
Twitter at Jacob deck for more on all
things gaming in Witcher hit that
subscribe button